welcome to this video playing hoops no
not displease point playing a little
panda here from mrs. netherlands norway
gypped as a solace yeah well whatever ok
m and dwell miss figuring miss reading
this flag we got into a Kings Indian
attack yeah there are all kinds of
possible setups against this this is one
of them b6 is another one yeah this
fields are almost like an e4 e5 opening
and one issue of these e 45 positions as
apparent as well than knight on c6 very
often is misplaced after white as some
plates III this is one of them go waltz
in this position try to UM make sure
that this night got something to do
alright but first let's see if I can get
in Bishop e6 Bishop a 60 it's just
sucking the exchange without further ado
okay
yeah yes I can never be enough really
but it splits Jess 2075 95 we'd be five
or something what is there some some
other possibility yeah but this is I
guess simple and good
Queen B 5 I can even just just take you
five
yeah I guess an exchange up maybe as c4
is a possible a possible threat okay he
wants to grab here but I don't really
mind you to take on that form
you should pay 89 takes h3 should be it
should be excellent for black check
yahoo gage five isn't this like complete
complete devastation
very hard to understand what he's doing
here no mate don't ok so let's keep the
threat into in this position I just have
this year but then let's check first if
it's really really the best move
you cannot take Queen age 38 stew is
mate but you can play king to g1 and
it's not a mate then at least I don't I
don't see one that's some other way to
improve on that ayah maybe maybe this
one threatening Queen to h3 this is
easier if you move the King I take
default f3 is hanging out this is this
is easiest Queen a tree it's just a
deadly threat
so just to take on there three years
there some buttons Queen d2 for example
a 26 for example intending to go here
if I take it yeah k mean it's it should
be should be more than enough
white resigns yeah are too hard to
figure out what made him exchange sexy
exchanges or so quickly I don't really
think it was was necessary was it Queen
Queen e2 or something the contact she
points out this this idea with good gave
the black home maybe but yes still it
feels weird to sack the exchange after
like three seconds because it's very
clearly insufficient yeah now it's just
an exchange this check this is really a
really deadly alright thanks for
watching